an
outpouring of reassurance at the office
of the polish social and cultural
association
after xenophobic graffiti appeared on
the front door
gestures of love far outweighed the
hatred hundreds of emails coming in
thanking us and saying we're sorry
please don't take it that all
english people think like this we love
you
children from the local school
demonstrating outside our building this
morning with their mothers demonstrating
their support for us
all these people coming in with cards
and flowers
well wishes you know we're very very
comforted by this in the west london
district of hammersmith
more than two-thirds of the electorate
voted to remain in the eu
so they're all the more shocked and
dismayed that the referendum result
has unleashed a spate of xenophobic
crimes
it's sullying the good name of
our country which i think by and large
is pretty tolerant
but recently some of the worst in us
has come out and i
it it saddens me very much that's a
feeling shared by many in this area
young stangrich lived through the
nationalism of the 20th century
and fought on the side of the british
against the nazis
given the current eruption of racist
behavior he can't help but be reminded
of europe's darkest chapter
in living memory i think it is
almost coming so close
as it emerged in certain countries
before the second war
because it is just now we could
say is heading in almost same
direction yes but
most of his compatriots living in
hammersmith are resolved
not to let it get them down even if
recent events have left a horrible
aftertaste what's happened
it hurts because that hits our hearts
but i doubt that that some sort of you
know
incident would scare people off
bart golinski wants to remain in england
and he won't let anyone take his
newfound home away from him